des bioshock criminels condamnés elles
étaient présentes le soir de nocif et
donc dans trois semaines et demie le mef
organise son grand bal annuel et nous
allons le braquer j'adore 16 millions et
demi de dollars
sur chacun de vos comptes c'est une
sacrée somme chaque centimètre carré est
sous surveillance c'est le système de
sécurité le plus perfectionné au
amis combien de temps à planifier sa
cinquante huit mois et d'eau chaude
pourquoi tu besoin de le faire parce que
c'est mon truc
dupont que la fête commence
l'ordure
top départ
[Musique]
allier
je suis passé préparé pour ça
[Musique]
ne seront pas suspecte de ce crime point
barre
elle tombe à chaque fois plus la bouche
il faut crever la bouche
qu'est ce que tu fais je les allumés
[Musique]